what was it that you saw today um we was
next to the to the fiddle antique
shopping mall I'm just going up to the
Olympic tower having good few about ova
Munich and there was a lot of police and
firefighters that we said okay let's
wait to get up and then the breaking
news came and a lot of helicopters are
around this area now a lot of police
public transportation stuffs the bmv BMW
headquarter closed the museum and also
the Olympic towers very very crazy are
you still seen at the moment can you see
what's happening now um we can see a
helicopter yeah just in time they come
more police cars lot of emergency cars
and but but the areas so that no one can
get in we are close to that on a hat on
the hill the margin from what you can
see and what you saw before and do you
get the sense that the police are
concerned about what could be a
situation that is still ongoing I don't
think so that no than normal police cars
going to this place but yeah I don't
know I can't we are not close enough to
to to say that other